Let's get back to the phones we now we call
them phones.
They're really the Internet tubes.
We're taking calls via discord at David Pakman
dotcom discord.
Let's go to Jane from Singapore, Jane from
Singapore.
You're on the air.
Hi.
Hi, how are you?
I am very well, thank you.
Well, I'm surprised you called them in.
Oh, no, I said Jane from Singapore is exactly
what we would gravitate towards.
I, I think that your show has been very enlightening
for me.
Thank you.
And I basically signed up to be a member because
I watched your video with this this other
guy.
I can't remember his name, though.
And basically I thought you were.
So he was a right wing believer, I believe.
And you were just so polite and so conversational
and so accepting of listening to his views.
And I just respected him so much.
Wow.
I know who that was.
Was it was it may be Tim Pool.
Was he wearing a hat during the interview?
No, it was it was a black guy who who could
sing.
Ali Peterson.
Jesse Lee Peterson.
Yes, that's right.
God, it's the one.
Got it.
So, I mean, I think that, you know, the way
the US system has been running is that this
is a great disappointment because we all look
to the US as honestly a shining beacon of
democracy.
And I'm just wondering honestly how how the
system would run with I mean, even Republican
showing a great drift.
You know, on one hand, you have a bunch of
guys who are denying that the election's outcomes
are illegitimate.
On the other hand, people are saying, you
know, uphold election results.
The Republicans are saying there's no fraud.
How does that even work in a party?
How do you go forward from here?
Yeah, I mean, listen, it's it's really a question
for them to answer, because as someone who's
on the left, I see it and I say this is corrosive
and destructive to democracy.
This is going to lead to if this is believed
by a significant portion of the population,
it's going to lead to all sorts of follow
on problems.
To me, it seems untenable and unsustainable.
Now, it's interesting that you're saying from
the perspective of looking at what's going
on from Singapore, it's not so much that you
find it funny.
You find it disturbing, it sounds like.
I do, yeah, I find it, I find it how how Trump
has weaponized the two words, fake news, right?
Very disturbing people.
How do people raise kids on such values?
I mean, you know, there's all this talk about
the recovery healing the country.
But do the people, Democrats and Republicans,
the people on the street, do actually take
the first steps to what recovery to was conversation
to a dialog?
No, of course there isn't.
In fact, I would expect so if Donald Trump
announces that his twenty, twenty four candidacy
soon, I think that we will have four years
of of insanity once again.
And I think that either way, the presence
of these propaganda media outlets like Newsmax
and own that are going to mean they are going.
I can't even guess what sorts of conspiracies
they will come up with about Joe Biden over
the next four years.
It's going to be the opposite of healing that
we see here.
Can I ask a question just just to get your
viewpoint?
Yeah.
Do you think that Donald Trump would try to
cut a deal with the DOJ, perhaps to say, you
know, I will I will completely accept the
election results if you guys just not charge
me or pursue any sort of criminal investigations?
No chance.
Because so so because here's the thing.
Here's the thing, Jack.
If he does it now, it's his own DOJ.
So so that that doesn't make sense.
And then that's not something that the Biden
deal.
I mean, Biden will be president in a month,
you know, so Biden doesn't need to cut any
deals with anybody.
And I don't see I think the only way Trump
can get himself out of trouble preemptively
would be resign and Mike Pence pardons him.
I don't think he will do it.
But there are rumors he's thinking about it.
I see, because this is what we're talking
about in Singapore, we're sort of betting
that he would he would step down in peace
and say, I would give your country peace only
if you do not prosecute me.
So I don't think that will happen.
I don't think that will happen.
No.
Right.
Anyway, good luck and all the best, and I
hope that there would be a very smooth and
gorgeous inauguration ceremony for Biden.
Thank you, Jane.
Jane from Singapore, very much appreciate
the call.
Great to hear from folks not just all over
the country, but all over the world . Let's
go next to let's go to Kyle from Daytona Beach,
Florida.
Kyle, Daytona Beach, Florida.
You're on the air, Mr. Pacman.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Excellent.
It's a pleasure to speak with you.
The pleasure's all mountaineer's.
Thank you.
Thank you, your content is very intellectually
stimulating.
It's a nice reprieve from everything that
I have to hear everyday living in a red state.
Thank you.
Now, I know that some people are going to
get mad at me because they say, listen, I
haven't brought up anybody's connection at
all, but we are getting sort of like an electricity
type static as well as a banging noise.
So I'm wondering what you're doing.
I'm sitting on my bed.
I can turn off the thing in my bedroom door.
You're not crinkle on pieces of paper over
the phone by chance.
Wow.
Oh, my God, we're going to have to turn that
down.
That isn't.
OK, yeah, we're going to have to disconnect.
That's just that was I don't even know that
that's legal in some states.
We're going to I really want to hear from
you, but we're going to have to get I can't
subject the audience to that.
And the audiologists in the audience are filing
lawsuits.
So not going to be able to do that at this
point in time.